[Music]
you do meet people from time to time who
are extraordinarily disciplined
but most of the time they've got
disciplined in exactly this manner
it's through slow incremental
improvement the only thing you're
missing is momentum i think a lot of
people
they will go from their full-time job
quit they have very
meager savings and suddenly they're like
this has to work
well now you've put yourself in a bad
position yeah
rise and shine it's ice crystal time
hey it's evan carmichael and i am not a
boring person
i'm not but when you start your day with
a routine that
inspires you consistently like watching
one of these videos
it will change your life so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee
know that i believe in you and get ready
for a shot of espresso from jordan
peterson i wake up
every morning
take a bit of a look at yourself and
think about what's not so good
that you could improve that you should
improve by your own
standards and that you would improve you
know
and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this
stack of paper there you know and you
haven't looked at that damn stack for
like a month
and you know that you should be and
you're boy bothering yourself at night
because you're avoiding that
it's like maybe think i've avoided that
stack of paper completely for one month
i'm quite a coward when it comes to
whatever snakes might be hidden in that
stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like i glance through it for
15 seconds see if i can do that
it's like well you set yourself a goal
of improvement you know it's a humble
goal
because really are you such a coward
that the best that you can bloody well
manage after a month of avoidance is 15
seconds of exposure to a stack of paper
you know it could easily be you've been
avoiding it you're obviously afraid of
it and so
the situation could be that dismal and
dire
and you might think well geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no it's
it's no it's not fostering the strength
of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of
and so that's a form of humility too
it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction
and then the question is are you big
enough to take those small
steps you know are you capable of
grappling with the fact that you're
fundamentally flawed to the point where
you have to break things down into
almost
child-like steps in order to manage them
and the answer to that is yeah you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined
but most of the time they've got
disciplined in exactly this manner
it's through slow incremental
improvement and then
you challenge yourself it's like well
could i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out
generally you get better at it and you
can take on larger and larger challenges
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got
great ideas great ideas that can change
maybe the world but certainly change
your life your family's life the people
around you your customers
great ideas you're doing things for the
right reason you want to serve you want
to help
and you want to make a lot of money
you've got it in you you have the
potential
sitting here right in front of you the
only thing you're missing momentum
momentum momentum we need mo
momentum it's not happening because
you're not
staying consistent enough on the
momentum
it's it's i think one of the biggest
problems that entrepreneurs face
it's not a lack of ideas it's a lack of
execution
consistent execution getting started
and then consistent execution and it's
why i spend so much
time helping at least attempting to help
entrepreneurs believe in themselves more
because that
gives you the courage the permission the
optimism to go and actually take the
steps
i was talking to a mastermind group last
night
it's a pretty high level group of people
who you know was invited to be their
keynote speaker or special guest i guess
for the month
and we were talking about youtube and
getting started on youtube
and why youtube this year i think is the
number one
strategy that if you are a thought
leader and expert you have to go
in on youtube you'll get incredible
results
for your business and so i was
explaining it and people are like
nodding and like yeah
yeah it's like okay but what's the
problem like why are you not gonna make
a video
the problem is people are too concerned
about it being perfect
well what camera do i use and what
microphone do i use and what lighting do
i use
and guys i'm sitting here in my car
on my phone with no you know whatever
light
the the sun making videos well my wife
is shopping at costco
right can you see the can you see the
costco sign there
it is costco here at costco
nina's shopping i'm making videos let's
go
how long have i i've been doing this for
since april 2009
and i'll still make videos it's not that
i disrespect the fancy gear and
everything else but
if you're a thought leader what matters
is you teach people to think like you
think
and we get so caught up on things being
perfect having that perfect first step
that we don't do anything at all
that's the problem you're so worried
about having the perfect first step
that you don't do anything at all
meanwhile your dream slowly dies inside
you
because you're not feeding it you're not
giving it oxygen you're not
given any kind of momentum thinking
about it alone isn't enough
thinking about it alone it might even be
a form of torture because you know
you're capable of more
you know that you could do it you know
it's a great idea
and yet you don't do enough consistent
action on it to actually ever realize it
meanwhile you see somebody else there's
somebody else out there
with less intent with less heart
with less passion with less purpose than
you winning
off of your idea because they just did
something because they're out doing it
imperfectly
and you're worried about getting the
perfect first step i tell the story of
me
losing a 40 million deal in my 20s
because i was trying to be too perfect
i'm still a recovering perfectionist i
would love
everything to be perfect fully
recognizing that that's never going to
happen
but having a release schedule forces me
to
make stuff videos have to go up today
a video has to go up today it has to so
i have to record it
is it if it's an ideal setting great and
it's not an ideal setting great
i filmed a video recently going through
a car wash
because a video had to get recorded and
i hope the audio came out well enough
you guys to listen to
and i'm not delaying let's go let's
let's great let's go make a video as we
drive to a car wash
that's gonna happen because no matter
how much of a perfect plan you think
you're trying to make at the beginning
as soon as you go out and start to do it
you realize that your planning wasn't
perfect at all
you just don't know enough to make a
perfect plan it's a problem
you don't know enough to make a perfect
plan and if you're thinking about you
know back to youtube videos you're going
to make youtube videos but you're not
going to start to get the lights and the
gear and the camera and everything else
and learn how to edit and what programs
to use
nothing matters more than recording
and putting up the video you want to do
that other stuff in your spare time
great
but you do that after you actually
record a video and post it
and then tomorrow record another video
and post it and then the next day record
another video and post it
with no editing just put it up and then
you slowly get better doing the thing
because momentum is the missing
ingredient so how do we make this
practical how do we
take your idea and turn it into
something tangible real something
you can take action on today a couple
ideas for you the first is what i call
the two percent difference
the two percent difference the two
percent difference is you've got this
big giant idea which is great i love it
i
mean
the big mission the big goal is the
thing that keeps you motivated inspired
ready to go to work
happy about your life right like where
you're going you need that big mission
and you have to figure out what's the
first two percent
if your goal back to youtube is to is to
have a youtube channel that's successful
and drives traffic and revenue
and impact for you great what's what's
the first two percent
of action not research researching a
video camera is not two percent action
the first two percent is making your
first video
is it perfect no but it's the first two
percent
stop trying to get 100 before you start
two percent the first two percent go
make
create whatever that is for you and your
business and your in your goals
if you've got a health goal how much
time do you spend researching the
perfect diet researching the perfect
fitness plan researching
and then never doing like researching
how to do squats and push-ups
will not help you until you actually do
a push-up
the first two percent is to go and do as
many push-ups as you can
can you do four push-ups great do four
push-ups
will those four push-ups lead to massive
results for you
not physically but mentally yes
because you did something because you've
proven to yourself that you
are an action taker that you do
something you you build momentum
towards the goal and then tomorrow you
do another four push-ups and the next
day you do
six push-ups and the next day maybe you
can do seven push-ups and
all of those little wins stack that
momentum stacks it builds up
so find the first two percent okay it's
super super important and take some kind
of action
on it we don't give ourselves credit for
reading watch this video doesn't count
reading doesn't count listen to a
podcast doesn't count researching
doesn't count
action doing something the two percent
difference
the second thing that i give advice on
to help you is
expect to suck at the beginning
expect to suck expect it to suck and
when you first try something you don't
expect to be great
but you usually don't expect to suck as
bad as you
suck in your head you might be thinking
okay i can do 10 push-ups i'm not going
to be able to do
100 push-ups i'm not going to be arnold
schwarzenegger or whoever
i'm not going to do that many but i can
do at least ten and then you do it and
you do four
you don't expect to suck as badly as you
actually suck right again not suck as a
human just
you don't have the skill set yet or
develop the muscles yet
when you make a youtube video you don't
expect to be great you don't expect to
be tony robbins
on your first video but when you record
it
and then you watch it back you don't
expect to be as bad as you were
right you watch your back oh my god i
didn't expect to be great but holy cow
i didn't expect to be this bad either
right and then that kills momentum
that sucks the air out of it that if you
have the expectations of being
not a hundred but being a 10 and you
come in at a four
you don't ever get back and do it again
you don't make another video you don't
do another push-up you don't take the
next step because you expect it to be
better than you were
what you need to recognize is your first
attempt at something is going to be the
worst
that video you just made those push-ups
you just did will be the worst ones
that you ever do and that if you keep
going you're going to get better
tomorrow's video will be a little
better and the next video will be a
little bit better your push-ups will get
a little bit better
every time right by taking the action
you get a little bit better
through the process so the one that you
recorded today the thing you did right
now the first two percent
will be the worst that you ever do so
don't quit on the worst try
you get up and you do it again get a
little bit better tomorrow so that's why
i say expect to suck expect it to be
brutal
expect it like the fact that you pressed
record and you said anything at all and
didn't vomit on your phone
is a win right expect to suck and again
it doesn't mean that i expect to suck as
a person
you just don't have the skill set yet
and how do you
develop the skill set by by practicing
by doing the work by
making another video right and then the
third thing is to tie your
self-esteem yourself forth yourself
belief to the effort
we tend to tie our self-worth to the
result how good of a project did i
get the how many push-ups that i do if i
didn't do 10 i feel like
a loser right instead you tie yourself
worth to the effort
if you can really embrace those three
things you'll start to
build massive momentum towards your
goals
number one the two percent difference
what's the smallest possible way for you
to get started towards your goal
number two expect to suck expect the
first version of whatever you're doing
to just be
absolutely terrible it's amazing it's
the best
and then number three tie your
self-worth your self-love your
self-belief
to the effort that you're putting in
every single day do those three things
finally build some momentum towards the
goals
the mission the dream that you have
because your dream is worthy of it
your goals are worthy of it you as a
human are worthy of it
you've got this thing that you know
you're capable of more that you know you
want to breathe into the world
that's going to serve and help and
contribute and build the life for you
and your family that you want
it's all possible but not
without momentum do those three things
today
tomorrow the next day and it will change
your life
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put that down in the comments below
when you watch a video and just get
inspired
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
but if you get inspired and then create
a plan of action for when how and where
you are going to take action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 percent believe nation it's not
enough to just watch something we got to
create our plan
and when you commit publicly that number
jumps to 95
of you following through let's make that
happen your biggest takeaway from this
video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate with
you also if you want to have more
self-love self-confidence self-belief
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive
action to build that habit to create
that muscle
so i've created a 254 series where every
day for 254 days i will send you a video
for
free to help you shift your confidence
and belief forward the link to join is
in the description
below if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about well you have to treat
yourself like you matter
because if you don't then you don't take
care of yourself and you become vengeful
oh no you're okay you should feel good
about yourself like
you're you're fine the way you are it's
like you think well that's a calming
message for people
it's something i encourage a lot of
entrepreneurs to think about i think a
lot of people
they will go from their full-time job
quit they have very
meager savings and suddenly they're like
this has to work
well now you've put yourself in a bad
position yeah so either
start it while you have a full-time job
do it on the side and don't tell me you
don't have time you have time
and the second thing is build up your
savings your savings are going to give
you the runway or the flexibility
to try different things a business is
not easy
especially going from zero to one it's
pretty hard
and if you're under a time crunch where
you have like two months of cash left
you're going to start making bad
decisions yeah if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there